more than a hundred people have been
arrested following days of rioting in
the solomon islands police also found
three bodies in a burnt out building
much of the violence has been in the
chinatown district of the capital
honiara tensions over links with china
are largely behind the anger directed
against the government of the south
pacific nation
picking up the pieces after days of
unrest in the solomon islands
large parts of the capital honiara have
been reduced to ruins
this was the scene after rioters set
fire to a number of buildings
the city's chinatown neighborhood was
one of the main targets of violence
security has been stepped up outside
prime minister manassa sugavari's home
after it came under attack
protesters unhappy with his government
are demanding his resignation
seen here during a 2019 visit to beijing
is seen by some islanders as beholden to
chinese interests
the solomon islands archipelago is rife
with ethnic tensions
residents of the most populous island
are especially angry over the
government's decision to switch
allegiance from taiwan to mainland china
there's also widespread dissatisfaction
over high youth unemployment
so far the government has shown little
willingness to address the protesters
concerns
neighboring australia was quick to
respond to a call for help in boosting
security
though our role is very clear we're
there as a result of a direct approach
from the solomon islands government in
the in accordance with the treaty that
we entered into
uh with them in 2017 so
we're there to support the police force
an overnight curfew and foreign troops
have helped restore calm
but they won't resolve the underlying
tensions to prevent a repeat of the
unrest